many of you don't have to be told that
Donald Trump's mental health is poor
that his cognitive state is poor and if
you've been following his presidency or
watching this show you know Trump's
unstable you know appear that Trump
appears to be declining cognitively he's
often confused loses his train of
thought his brain will glitch coinciding
with these weird shoulders spasms it's
very very odd and disturbing you might
suspect that the entire coronavirus
Fiasco may not be improving Donald
Trump's cognitive state and you would be
right if you've been paying attention
this would not be a surprise because
it's been visible at press conferences
it's been visible via the tweets and we
have a new report out from psychiatrist
dr. Justin Frank who's been a guest on
the program about Donald Trump's mental
health deterioration now before you jump
all over me and say David Goldwater rule
Goldwater rule it's unethical if
somebody hasn't personally examined
Trump to evaluate his cognitive state
remember the Goldwater rule was created
specifically to stop criticism about
senator Barry Goldwater back in the
1960s the Goldwater rule is no objective
standard there's not a consensus about
the Goldwater rule if applied to Trump
the Goldwater rule would silence
countless mental health professionals
from pointing out the obvious about
Donald Trump dr. Justin Frank predicted
that given Donald Trump's total lack of
empathy lack of ability to take
responsibility ever we should expect to
see Trump doing exactly what he is now
doing shrugging off all responsibility
for the virus response ignoring the
mounting death toll often not even
mentioning it during his press briefings
instead talking about ratings and
popularity everything that dr. Justin
Frank has been predicting and told us on
our show and that he has been observing
is coming true Trump tweeting about his
ratings while the bodies pile up
yesterday saying because the ratings of
my news conferences are so high bachelor
finale Monday night football type
numbers the lamestream media is going
crazy
Trump is reaching too many people we
must stop him
said one lunatic here's Trump saying he
takes no responsibility for any
thing her fout she said earlier this
week that the lag in testing was in fact
a failing do you take responsibility for
that and when can you guarantee that
every single American who needs a test
will be able to have a test what's the
date of that yeah no I don't take
responsibility at all because we were
given a a set of circumstances and we
were given rules regulations and
specifications
dr. Justin Frank believes Trump is a
sociopath having no feelings of care
concern or empathy for other humans
dr. Justin Frank is worried that Trump
is actually unable to feel guilt or
remorse and his public presence as
president for more than three years
seems to confirm that he doesn't seem to
care about the death toll his mental
state is deteriorating in part because
he's unable to do his Magga alleys in
part because everything around him is
crumbling but it just doesn't compute
with his self perception with how he
views himself so the daily coronavirus
briefings are kind of how Trump is
getting his fix given that he can't do
the stadium Magga rallies he this goes
well beyond just narcissistic
personality disorder it's more
complicated it's more serious but it's
nothing new it's just far more dangerous
when the person is promoted from just
doing you know real-estate deals in
Manhattan to being president and being
responsible for the country's response
to a pandemic it can only get worse we
are literally in the position of trying
to limit the death precipitated by
Donald Trump this isn't a good place to
be
dr. Justin Frank has been spot on in his
analysis so far if we have to say is
there anything good Trump extended the
guidelines 30 days and said stay the
hell home that's good okay and hopefully
by the end of April we will be on the
decline of the curve that's the hope
remains to be seen